[Musique]
le président du département cyrille
melchior s'est rendu à la mj r
l'association pour l'éducation de la
jeunesse réunionnaise situé à saint
pierre
la jr
existe depuis
1967 et elle a démarré par les par les
frères des écoles chrétiennes
le premier président qui a encore l'envi
qu'ils notre président d'honneur c'est
le frère michel et depuis 55 ans elle a
continué son oeuvre
c'est-à-dire d'apporter aux jeunes et
surtout aux jeunes blessés par la vie
d'apporter donc du réconfort da
considération et de leur permettre un
avenir qui soit un avenir positif et un
avenir vivable
l'association financée par le
département gère une maison d'enfants
accueillant près de 60 jeunes âgés de 6
à 18 ans qui ont besoin d'une prise en
charge adaptée d'un accompagnement de
leur évolution scolaire sociale et
affective
le département est dans son rôle
d'accompagner des partenaires qui
s'investissent à nos côtés quoi faire en
sorte que dans tous les domaines de
l'action sociale est bien connu les
meilleurs résultats aussi bien pour les
jeunes en difficulté d'insertion pour
les barons qui parfois rencontre aussi
des difficultés dans leur rôle mais
aussi beaux les personnes âgées comme
pour les personnes porteuses de handicap
dans tous ces domaines nos partenaires
non
essentiels et je tiens à le dire un
grand merci et à tous les jeunes
réunionnais je leur renouvelle toute ma
confiance et tous mes voeux de réussite
les jeunes ont présenté au président les
différents projets artistiques qu'ils
ont réalisés mais également à leur
projet de randonnée jusqu'à mafate qui
se déroulera prochainement
[Musique]